foreign
Christian Is With Us in Greensboro North
Carolina hi Christian welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Dave uh yes so I was calling because
I had a question I have uh six million
dollars worth of uh property here in the
area and
um uh oh almost three million dollars
about 2.8 million in uh in loans uh my
question was do you think it's wise to
sell some of my portfolio to pay off the
loans and be debt free or should I
utilize the monthly cash flow to pay off
the loans uh fast what do you think
well congratulations you've done a good
job you got a good Equity position
and you've obviously got a going concern
and uh you there's a lot of different
ways to attack uh the situation where
you are you can keep doing more of what
you've been doing
um here's what I learned when I had uh
when I was 25 years old 24 years old I
had four million dollars worth of Real
Estate
and I owed three million on it so I did
not have as good an equity position as
you do
okay I was about about 75 loan to value
you're about 50 all right but I ended up
losing everything
because the bank got sold to another
bank called our notes we had a lot of
flip notes out on 90 day notes and it
caught me and took me out
and what I learned from that going broke
process in my 20s 30 years ago was that
uh those of us that love real estate
people like you and me Christian uh
sometimes we forget to measure risk
Common Sense tells you an actual
business analysis tells you that the
more debt you have the more risk you
have would you agree with that
yes indeed okay and what I've discovered
now over 30 years not only of teaching
these things but of living a completely
debt-free life and I today on several
hundred million dollars worth of Real
Estate
um and uh what I've discovered in that
process building that portfolio a
different way over this 30 years is that
the lack of risk
with having no debt
has accelerated over the Long Haul the
amount of real estate I can own
because I don't make as many mistakes I
don't have setbacks I don't have cash
flow problems I've always got cash
can you imagine how much cash my real
estate throws off with no debt
it's obscene okay and uh so but and
that'll I can buy another piece of real
estate with just cash flow fairly often
it uh because we've got tremendous rents
coming in on these things now
so all that to say what I have learned
from my personal walk and from walking
with others is that where where I know
you will be the best off in 10 years and
have the most wealth because of the
lowered risk and the increased peace in
your life
um
is if you were debt free now do we have
to burn everything down and do this
suddenly because you just you and I had
a conversation no I think you have a
gradual process and you say okay over
a year two years three years whatever it
is I'm gonna move in that direction
because if I were in your shoes I would
rather have four million dollars of paid
for Real Estate than six million dollars
of real estate with three million
dollars worth of debt
very true and that's about where you all
be because your real estate will go up
in value while we're doing this
all right so how long you've been doing
this apparently you've been doing it a
while and you're good at it
well I've been doing it since uh 2012. I
actually used my W2 to help me purchase
property and I was also flipping at the
time yeah okay and uh in 2019 I decided
to uh leave my job because I was able to
sustain uh seeing myself and uh yeah and
all the bills yeah and so you're doing
flips in addition to this
yeah well sleeps are more so like uh for
fun it's more I do flips maybe two three
times a year okay uh yeah but it's good
pocket money okay yeah you can probably
live off your flips and then your your
other stuff just generates income that's
awesome well done good for you well
here's what I figured out when I'm doing
a flip I buy something differently
if I'm paying cash
and when it is paid for I am in no rush
to sell it
so my yeah my my I never become a
motivated seller or a motivated buyer
and I get better deals on the buy and I
sell for higher on the sale
because I got all kinds of patience with
no payments
but when the payment's eaten you're
eating your back pocket out
it makes you want to jump and get rid of
that thing you know what I'm saying
exactly and I've been following you for
quite a while and uh I would like to be
debt free uh at some point uh that's why
uh have you got any properties that are
higher LTV that are 80 90 LTV
uh no like uh usually when I when I
borrow it's really really low I mean
you're at about 50 on the portfolio if
what if you don't have any that are
higher than that they're all about 50
percent
no not at all okay
that would be the first ones I divest
but since you don't have those what I
would do is just look at the portfolio
and go okay 10 years from now which one
of these suckers do I want to own
and start going okay I'm gonna use some
some cash flow and knock out a few and
I'm gonna liquidate I don't know a
couple million dollars worth or million
dollar million and a half worth or
whatever it comes out to be and you know
between those two things have a two or
three year plan to be free
because again you're gonna you're gonna
be wealthier and you're gonna have a
better life if you start with four
million dollars of paid for Real Estate
three years from today
I'm not arguing with that I think I
think he got a I think he got the nice
day version of that that was great well
he's he the reason is is because he's
actually pulling it off yeah he's not he
he could probably survive
and not and do and you know 10 years now
you start doing this nothing down real
estate crap on Tic Tac uh you're not
gonna survive 10 years yeah because all
the guys that I knew doing that in any
generation have gone broke including me
so uh but he's sitting in a 50 Equity
position so he's gonna cash flow uh and
if he manages the property well and he's
been doing it a decade already yeah so
that tells me he's really got his crap
together but now we're down to the
simple of philosophy is you start asking
yourself is this debt-free thing really
better and the actual end result of the
data is yeah you end up better not just
a better feeling right you end up with
more money well yeah you laid that out
really clearly
I think that he has a a good strategy
for him and something that he can start
walking towards which is really cool you
know those of you that are playing with
real estate or want to play with real
estate let me just tell you something
you will never put in you will be less
likely never you can always do something
stupid you will be less likely to put a
bum tenant in a property when you don't
have any payments
but when you got payments you're looking
for somebody to pay those payments with
their rent
and you're you're more desperate as a
landlord to fill your vacancies and
you're more likely to go well I know I
kind of had a bad feeling
turns out she was doing drugs who knew
wow but you know I mean whatever it is
right and you put a tenant in there
that's a bum and then you've got a mess
they tear up the place you go through
you still go through six months with no
income you go through an eviction you go
through all this stuff bankruptcies on
them everything else it's a mess but you
won't Overlook that if you're going
I don't think unless you really make me
feel good that I'm going to let you have
the privilege of living in my property
because I don't have any problems now
and I don't need you to bring your
problems to me that's such a good point
yeah so you just desperate landlords
make stupid decisions like desperate
people of any kind and it ends up
costing them more yeah and yeah you get
you do get you get bit you get really
bit and I've done both I've been both
it's been a long long time since I've
put in a a weak tenant
because I had to because I haven't been
there in decades now and so I'm just
really encouraging folks there's a
there's a way to do this real estate
thing where it turns out really nice and
there's a way to do it where you go
broke so and Christian's in the middle
this is a good question